i remember there was only one time i
ever wanted to go to the hospital and it
was uh
this one specific hospital that i think
i went to one time had uh
a gamecube right when it came out and i
was like what is this mythical hospital
right yeah but why don't more hospitals
do that and i was like all right next i
saw it and i was like
i saw i was leaving i was like next time
i'm coming i'm going to play it and then
i went
and someone [ __ ] stole the
controllers so they had a game shoot a
gamecube
they're like super mario sunshine super
mario strikers super mario party brawl
they're bored somehow
that's why you could even buy that game
often like yeah why did they have this
at a hospital
i think it was like a charity had given
them a donate just like a
a room where it was like it was when i
was like 12 so yeah
kids but
some [ __ ] [ __ ] stole a [ __ ]
gamecube controller from a children's
hospital
that have been donating from a charity
what
who does that who does that i hope it's
only a mouth where he looks i hope it's
another
gonna get in trouble i don't know if
this is a controversial incident
controversial
i don't even know i don't even know if
if it is we apologize
i just can't take that insult seriously
anymore apparently it's a
it was an insult back in the 1940s 40s
america
so 40s it's been around that long jesus
christ
this is the first i'm hearing of it this
is like this is like if i taught you the
word busting you found out it was racist
or something
like [ __ ] i've been saying the whole
episode jesus christ i
i want to know the motivation if
somebody steals a gamecube controller
from a that's all right it was already a
rare console at the time
honestly it's probably another kid right
it's probably another kid another kid
who just
doesn't have a game keep always wanting
a game or they stole a gamecube from
somewhere forgot the controllers
yeah how are you like because gamecubes
at that time i think were quite
expensive
and they were i mean the games weren't
cheap because it's nintendo yeah
so i mean the game's just you're rich
enough where your parents buy your
gamecube but not enough controllers so
you steal it from a kid's hospital
like what what an arsenal yeah i don't
know really strange really bizarre
[ __ ] that kid i was so excited to play
[ __ ] brawlers roblox
what were you in the hospital for yeah i
don't know i was getting checkups i
think
you're like mom mom can we go to the
hospital please mom
i know i went to the hospital a lot i
know i had a lot of i think injuries but
all of them ended up being like just
chill ones just like
whatever like blue sprains like not
nothing luckily like
never broke bones so wow yeah i don't
know how i got so lucky because i [ __ ]
my body up so many times i don't know
how i got so lucky
it's like why is my kid so enthusiastic
to go to the hospital
yeah and also sometimes you get like
your parents would like buy you like a
sweet or something afterwards they'd be
like yeah you get some like nice food
because you're oh hospital i thought
when you said sweet i thought you meant
like like a hotel sweetie
you're too adult jay they bought me a
sweet we call them sweets in the uk